so i didn't cover this yesterday but
more has happened and i do want to say a
little bit about it
a radical republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor green a major conspiracy
theorist a node of disinformation that's
n-o-d-e
my friends um i know i'll get emails
about that one
uh she was suspended from twitter for 12
hours now
you can interpret that as twitter is
finally
expanding its reach in terms of really
clamping down on the disinformation and
misinformation
or you could see it as 12 hours is
completely meaningless it's symbolic and
it merely provided marjorie taylor green
with the opportunity
to weaponize the ban and continue
perpetuating conspiracy theories
including about
social media vendettas against her which
do you think it was
mostly the second mostly the second i
mean 12
hours let's look at what we know about
it
new york times writing twitter suspends
marjorie taylor green for posting covet
misinformation
the republican lawmaker from georgia
cannot tweet for 12 hours
after the white house criticized social
media sites
for amplifying vaccine lies
twitter said on monday it was suspending
green
for 12 hours after she posted messages
that violated its policy
against sharing misleading information
about the coronavirus green of georgia
has been an outspoken opponent of
vaccines and masks as tools to curb the
pandemic
in tweets on sunday and monday she
argued that covid19 was not dangerous
from
four people unless they were obese or
over age 65
and said vaccines should not be required
now of course
they're not from the standpoint of any
kind of government mandate
there are private businesses and
institutions which
as an anti-regulation republican she
certainly should respect their ability
to
say here's who we want to do business
with or don't or here are the
requirements to work here as long as
they don't violate the law
the article goes on to say with cases of
the virus on the rise
and the highly contagious delta variant
accounting for more than half of new
infections
in the u.s federal health officials say
this month in miss green's home state
georgia new cases have increased 193
percent
in the past two weeks twitter said
green's tweets were misinformation and
barred her
until tuesday quote we took enforcement
action on the account
mt green e for violations of the twitter
rules specifically the covid19
misleading information
policy miss green said silicon valley
companies are working with the white
house to attack speech
free speech these big tech companies are
doing the bidding of the biden regime to
restrict our voices and prevent the
spread of a message that's not state
approved
twitter took action after biden called
on social media companies to do more to
combat the spread of vaccine
misinformation on their platform
biden said sites like facebook are
killing people
so you know the problem here is
of course marjorie taylor green is
spreading dangerous covet and vaccine
disinformation on twitter there's no
doubt whatsoever there's no doubt it
violates
twitter's terms of service the issue i
have is what are we really doing by
doing this for 12 hours now if it's this
is the first time it's 12 hours
and next time it'll be a week and next
time it'll be a full suspension
okay i could be convinced that taking a
lighter touch now
maybe makes some sense but the problem
is that this is all a closed loop
they claim that social media is
censoring them
they then post vaccine conspiracies that
are dangerous this and disinformation
so they get banned and then they say see
i told you so
i told you that they're censoring us i
told you that they're banning us
it's it's doxastic closure that's a term
i used before it's a logical
closure another way to say it is that
these are self-fulfilling beliefs
um it's a win-win in some sense for
marjorie taylor green
either she gets to keep peddling
disinformation on twitter
or she gets banned and then says
i'm a martyr they've canceled me i'm the
most cancelled woman or whatever the
case
so it ends up kind of being a gift i
think
it's better to ban her in a serious way
if she's going to be spreading the
disinformation which she is which
violates twitter policy
and as soon as she got back on twitter
because it was only a 12-hour ban
she first likened the suspension to
communist china
tweeting american social media company
twitter banned me for 12 hours
censoring me violating my freedom of
speech
that's of course not true twitter's a
private company they can enforce terms
of service
she said you know who else silences
sensors and bans people they don't like
and want heard
communist china communism is not good
save america stop communism you know who
else breathes
oxygen hitler right i mean that's
essentially what this is
then tweeting fouchy lied people died
fire fouchy then tweeting
a picture of herself doing a press
conference which we'll talk about
momentarily
captioning it communist style twitter
ban
press conference happening now and
then tweeting sports illustrated feats
featured a trans biological male
and an elite female tennis player this
year
do sports illustrated see the irony
in promoting a trans and
a female athlete when biological men
are now being allowed to defeat women in
women's
sports promoting men defeating
women is woke so immediately
going into more anti-science stuff
the fire fouchy attack fouchy thing is a
big anti-science movement now we're
going to talk more
about that tomorrow we talked about it
earlier today doing
anti-trans stuff she immediately should
be banned again if twitter actually
wants us to
believe that she's taking this seriously
next
i want to talk about
this press conference that she held
which is just completely out of this
world